hello calculator fanciers we have a real
treat today
a viewer a home amateur calculator
reviewer sent me in a calculator i have
never seen before this is the galaxy
and they emailed and said have you ever
seen a galaxy i said i had not and they
got this shipped to me direct from the
gaxio
warehouse wherever that may be and so on
the front you can see it's a galaxy o f
g
2 ms very nice there's a scientific
calculator on the back you have all the
options labeled it comes it comes with a
slide-on hard case loving that and oh
down the bottom there
made in china some of you may think the
galaxy is a little bit familiar looks
vaguely like something you've seen
before well i have here our previous
review we did of a casio a member of the
fx
series and you can see the surprising
similarities look at that they're pretty
much the same calculator just in
different packaging ones in a slightly
cheaper packet than the other other fact
you're now watching an unboxing video in
an unboxing video now blatantly the
calculators cannot accidentally be this
similar when i saw this it just sent
ripples through the calculator fancier
community everyone's outright i mean
surely if you're designing a calculator
at least design your own calculator
don't just rip off someone else's making
a cheap version of the calculator i mean
we are outrageous i will not let this go
down i i am i could not believe that
cassio just ripped off gaxio's fantastic
design so let's get in there and see
what the original has to offer now i am
a little hesitant to break the package i
don't have to cut into it if only it
came with a little tab so i could open
it in ah here we go look at that so i
can pop that open there look at that
just slid out what an action uh there's
uh the ends all the instructions are
bound so often i open a calculator the
instructions fly one way calculate the
other i never match them back up again
this it's all contained very nice put
that over there uh okay let's pop
the packet open
and we have
okay so there's the calculator and it's
slide on hard case okay so you can see
already this covers a variety of models
so if you own any of these and obviously
you're going to have more than one gacks
here around the place you can just look
them up in there very unfortunately it's
for the various fx models and what we
have here is actually the galaxy
fg
82 ms not covered by this set of
instructions now you might think this is
very suspicious that a galaxy fg series
calculator comes with instructions
something labeled the fx series and it's
cassio as we know who make the fx series
of categories
okay so that case did indeed
slide off
hard uh and oh here there's the inset in
there and you can see they've not glued
it in properly so if you decide you want
to remove it and stick it to the outside
like so
that is entirely oh i didn't quite okay
you get the idea anyways look at this
this is the fg series classic that's
good high quality manufacturing is only
galaxio can do okay i don't know who
quality control person 28 are but
whoever he or she is they know a perfect
calculator when they see one right let's
take this thing out for a spin two
square root oh it's around the wrong way
oh my goodness okay okay hang on so
sorry two square root equals nice
times
two
oh okay so they know if you're typing
two a second time you know what you've
typed why waste an entire part of the
display when they can show you a
fraction of it that they've simplified
and even down here they've taken chunks
off this number here so uh you don't
need all those extra digits and you can
see everyone knows the square root of 2
is
1.411 whatever that is 1 3.
okay here we go 2
equals
31.11 something okay
okay okay here hang on okay i'm gonna be
honest with you here 31.11
whatever that is it's not quite
two
but it's not 1.999 so you know it's it's
gone different
in all new and creative ways let's try
something a bit more down the line let's
put in pi so we've got pi down here okay
shift
pi
excellent
and let's just try multiplying it by one
to see if it can do that equals
three point one four one something nine
okay okay okay that's okay that's not so
bad let's try dividing by zero and see
what happens here one divide
zero
equals that's a meth error so this
calculator has had too much
math so when i was testing the inferior
knockoff casio fx i tried the square
root of 17 square root of 17. you simply
type square root of 17 you hit equals
and it tells you
that it's the square root
of 17. so let's see how this one does
without square root of 17 equals
a number okay let's multiply that by the
square root of 17 and that equals
hey hey it did it again i'm doubting
myself i'm going to redo root 2 times
root 2 equals
2. what did i do before
obviously the first calculation out of
the box is just a warm-up calculation
where it gives you a random kind of test
calibration number now it's it's it's
actually i converted as genuinely as
heating up it's now warmed up and ready
to go so as a whole it's quite it's got
quite a nice hand feel i mean it's got
these these kind of wings which which
are sweet and i mean the casio
calculators they're reasonably heavy
they've got what feels like a lot of
plastic whereas these i mean the galaxy
oh it's environmentally friendly it
doesn't use any more plastic than
absolutely necessary it's got a real
light kind of you know could go at any
moment feel i appreciate that dedication
to efficiency in manufacturing final
scores for the imported galaxia fx i
mean sorry fg none of that knock off
casio rubbish fg 82 ms for display it's
got a good display bits that seem to
come and go all the time though so i'm
going to give it an eight
or rather
most of an eight for functionality it's
got everything i need that'll be an
eight for accuracy i wanted to give it a
higher score but it's not quite there
every now and then so i'll drop the 10
down to an 8. ergonomics works well in
both hands i reckon it's around an 8.
for cred i mean it's got the galaxy oh
name what more do you need that's an 8
and for durability
obviously an eight that gives us a total
score of eight hundred and eighty eight
okay that's it look we're going to very
quickly check that in the instructions
so uh you can see here
uh it's not the english bit chinese
chinese chinese
no english
no other languages
okay so normally they have every
possible language here unless you're
fluent in chinese
symbols no luck but yes that's the
galaxy oh attention to detail